what is going on on the ground well
today is day 373 of Vladimir Putin's
10-day special military operation and on
the ground the Russians are attacking
into a number of different places the
main attack is backwood more on that in
a moment but they're attacking north of
north of bakmut
um trying to probe Ukrainian lines and
South in the Donetsk region and still
continue to attack civilian
infrastructure targets you know
overnight the ukrainians have claimed
that the Russians had 38 strikes in the
Donetsk oblast
um in the Ukrainian held part of that
against civilian targets
um but also at this time you the the
Russians have put out the fact that the
Russian defense minister shogu has gone
and visited the troops in the Donetsk
oblasca or that's what they're claiming
and they've put some video out of him
walking through the rubble and giving
medals and bits and pieces of the troops
we haven't managed to duplicate this
last time he allegedly visited the front
line this was visited somewhere else
carefully stage managed carefully stage
managed I don't think he's getting he
will go up there but progression and the
leader of the Wagner group criticized
him last time for not going there
there's a bit of a spat going on between
the two of them let's talk about Batman
if we may a pretty Stark assessment as I
was saying there from the ministry of
defense is Ukraine about to lose it it
is well I think Ukraine is holding the
Russians in position and your bakmut
itself it's it's not strategically
significant it was a city of about
seventy thousand
um the deputy mayor of Buckwheat this
morning assessed that was between four
and four and a half thousand people
still in in the city
um it gives some lines of communications
that would help the Russians but nothing
massive there's just this psychological
piece and the psychological piece I
think over the last seven plus months
the ukrainians have been running a very
very successful fixing operation and
fixing the Russians in there so they've
been throwing lots more troops in lots
of the Wagner group whilst they've been
um effectively killing them are treating
them and the Ukrainian Minister defense
assessment is for every one Ukrainian
Soldier lost the Russians are losing
seven
um uh and we've got the Russians now
attacking in from the south attacking in
from the north and they are circling it
there's one Road in that is now in
indirect fire
um mode for from the Russians that makes
it very difficult for the ukrainians to
continue to resupply the Troops that's
in there so maybe it's a time for them
with this fixing operation to withdraw a
little bit from buckmut city which has
been destroyed
um trade that space for additional time
they'll have prepared other defenses and
defensive positions further to the uh to
the West
um so think about the opportunity cost
effectively and um yes it's making sure
that they're you know they're not going
to lose too many troops for hanging on
to something that's really not worth
hanging on to yeah because it's more of
symbolic importance isn't it it is the
the other big thing is it's distracting
the Russians and everyone else from what
may be going on elsewhere yeah indeed uh
let's zoom out if we can
um globally how is all of this what's
going on there in Ukraine playing out
well globally the the seem to be split
there's those that support the
ukrainians primarily the west or Western
Union countries and then we've got the
likes of China and India Pakistan Iran
who are still sitting on the fence
Iran's not their supplying weapons but
we had the Russian foreign minister
lavrov in India
um last night he he gave a talk to say
the the war which we tried to stop was
launched against us using the Ukrainian
people and how did that go down to which
the Indian um crowd burst out laughing
so that would have been severely
embarrassing for the 72 year old
International Statesman that lavro Flex
to believe he still is and what's going
on but from a Global Perspective
um whilst the fighting is contained
inside Ukraine actually if you look at
the economic impact the great impact and
all the rest of it
um your grain exports affecting
sub-Saharan Africa and other poorer
countries the cost of living crisis
that's going up it is having a massive
Global impact and we're not quite
getting our information operation right
in explaining the globe that this is
because of Russia's invasion of Ukraine
because Russia are trying to say that
this is because of Western sanctions on
Russia